Hey, we wanna let you know that the final
Rhett and Link musical show
dates of the year and for--
The foreseeable future--
Are right, coming up on us.
So, November 20th through November 23rd,
we're gonna be in Albuquerque,
New Mexico, Phoenix, Arizona,
Sacramento, California and
Valley Center, California.
Go to rhettandlinklive.com
to grab those tickets.
We promise, we will make it
a very, very special
night worth your time.
Rhettandlinklive.com, go get them tix.
Now, on with the biscuit.
Welcome to "Ear Biscuits".
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are exploring the challenges
of maintaining a friendship.
We're not gonna necessarily talk about,
I mean I'm sure we will.
We're not talking about the
challenges in our friendship.
Maybe some of them will come out
as we talk about the challenges
in your friendships that
you have let us into.
Thank you for those of
you who have responded
to our props on the social
medias that we have asked
and told us about some of your situations
that you've got with your friends
that we're going to address.
Yeah.
If we've got anything, it's--
Good hair?
No, it's a friendship.
Oh, friendship, yeah.
It's friendship and with over 35 years
of that continuing to
happen, like constantly.
Friendship is still happening.
You know, it's--
Despite the doubts in the
comments from time to time.
Right.
And I would say
to be friends as long as we have
and to not get like
concerned comments from fans
who are only seeing us
through the lens of the lens--
Lens of the lens.
Would be, that would be weird.
I mean for us not to be
comfortable enough with each other
that sometimes, these honest
moments of tension come through
in the things we createm I
think that's a beautiful thing
because it's, again, it's those,
everything in friendship is not rosy.
Friendship, in general, is very difficult
and as I've look through these questions
that we're gonna discuss
from mythical beasts,
it's a good reminder of,
to me, about how much work it takes.
I don't wanna show our hand here
but it does take a lot of work
and there's no clear answers
because on any given day
in any given friendship,
there could be any scenario
that you've never experienced before
and you may not know anyone
who's been through it
so you kinda, like, what do I do?
So we'll talk about some of that.
Yeah, and like all relationships,
they have their projects that
have to receive attention
and so, hopefully, we
can offer some insights
but speaking of our friendship--
And viewing friendship as,
of your friend as a project,
it's maybe a bad place to start.
Well, you know what I mean.
It requires ongoing attention
but a person is not a project,
that's not what I meant.
But speaking of friendship
and maintaining friendships,
I mean we did something that
is just about as friendly
as you could possibly do.
We went and went on
paddleboats this past weekend.
Yeah, me and Rhett went out
on a paddleboat together.
Can you picture this two of us on,
at Echo Park, there's a lake which I guess
is called Echo Lake, is it?
I just call it Echo Park Lake.
I don't know if that's what it is.
Echo Park.
But--
Echo Park Lake.
It's like the most,
one of the most LA things
that you can do is get on--
Echo Lake?
Echo Park Lake.
Oh.
Is get on one
of these giant swans
that is a paddleboat that
can hold like five people
and paddle around this pond
and I've been by this place
so many times, and I've been like--
Me too.
Gotta get out on one of those paddleboats.
You'll see it in like,
if a commercial decides
to shoot in Los Angeles,
especially if they need
like a picturesque scene,
like if it's an ad for a medication,
they'll shoot at Echo Park.
Now, they'll film at such an angle
where like you can from
one side of the lake,
shoot across these fountains,
there's three fountains
that are grouped together
that shoot water, probably
50 feet in the air.
Straight up in the air.
And then you shoot past that
and you can see the skyline
of Downtown Los Angeles.
It's very beautiful.
But you just got to make sure that you,
that you film the proper angle
around the homeless encampments.
There are a few of those.
Right, yeah.
But they're very well--
They probably get them to leave
when they're about a shoot of commercial.
They're very well-maintained
homeless camps
because, I mean they're like,
there's a camp under this tree
and then you go to the
next stream there's a camp
but, I mean, they got nice
tents and there's this one guy,
he had a frigging, where we parked,
he had a flat screen
television beside his tent
and I was like, "How on earth?"
And then before I could get my answer,
I was like, "Oh, solar panels."
Yeah, a solar-powered--
Dude had solar panels--
Flat screen TV out there.
And a nice tent.
And so, it was like this
is prime real estate.
I made a note.
Right.
If I need to live out of a tent,
LA is a great place to be.
First of all, you've
got to get a flat screen
and a solar panel.
You gotta move to LA.
I'm already here.
And there's just so much going on.
I mean the thing about any
outdoor space in Los Angeles
on the weekend, really, anytime
but especially the weekend,
is there's just so much happening.
There's so many people there
and I know for a lot of people,
that can be a problem because you're like,
"Why can't I just go to an open space?"
Now, you can easily get to open spaces
where you won't see a soul, you
decide to go outside of town
but it was just like so many
people of all walks of life
almost as if the people
had been manufactured
for the sake of a movie.
Or for an insurance commercial.
Walking around--
I mean
medication commercial.
I mean you got people selling things.
You got this guy giving
free vegan ice cream samples
next to a guy selling--
Ceviche.
Chevice and then you got the taco place
and it's just, I don't
even know if these people
have licenses or permits.
I don't even care and then--
So picture me and Rhett holding hands
and skipping around this
lake together hopping on--
That exactly
how it happened.
Hopping on a swan
and just peddling out there
with our jean cutoff shorts.
Yeah, if you--
And our thighs--
I'm sorry to disappoint you--
Tanned.
But we actually didn't
get on the same swan.
My sister-in-law and two
nieces were in town and then,
I think your wife had the idea to be like,
"Hey, let's all go to the swans,
"let's all get on the paddleboats.
"Let's do this thing that
we've talked about doing
"for 10 years and we've never done."
So it was you and your
wife and two of your kids.
No.
One of your kids.
No, me and Christy were on a pedal boat,
and they call 'em pedal--
No, I'm just saying--
Not paddleboat,
by the way.
I'm just saying
who was there at this event.
And then my wife--
But we can do it by boat.
And my son.
So, me and Christy were on a boat.
And just you and Christy.
Just me and Christy.
I don't how you worked that out.
Because you volunteered
to take the youngest kid--
The kids, so Shepherd and
his first cousin Adeline,
my brother's daughter, is like,
they are each other's favorite people.
They're the same age.
Same age within like a couple months
and they just love each other,
they love spending time with each other,
they're into all the same
things and they just,
two peas in a pod as you say in the South.
And they really love to include
Lando, which is very cool.
He and Shepherd are really tight
but Lando's a little bit younger
so I think it's nice when Adeline
enters the equation that
they still wanna include him
and invite him over to
swim and stuff like that.
And by the way, you do know that Shepherd
jumps off of the roof
of the shed that covers
the back half of your patio.
Behind.
Into the pool.
Yeah, they recently
discovered they could do that.
Well, they invited Lando
over and then Lando comes,
we pick him up and he's coming back home
and you know how Lando is.
He like had this sheepish look on his face
and I remembered I was like,
"Lando, did you jump off
of the roof into the pool?"
He was like, "Yeah, Shepherd
told me I should do it."
Oh, Lando did it.
And he did it.
That's awesome.
And then he started crying.
He was like don't be mad at me.
I was like, "We're not mad at you."
Boy, Shepard has never
cried about anything
except not getting his way.
Definitely never cried about
getting caught for something.
So the three of them wanted
to be in the same boat
and then you stepped up to the plate.
Well, I knew an adult had,
I like being the fun uncle, you know.
The funcle.
And I'm quite a funcle and I was like
I'm gonna go out with
these kids, it'll be fun.
We can drive through,
I knew they would want
me to drive really close.
Drive, I think, paddle.
Do you drive a boat?
You do drive a boat
because there is a rudder.
They wanted me to go really
close to the giant fountains
because the wind is like blowing the water
that's going 50 feet in the air
and of course, you can go
right under it and get wet
and it's like going on
the log ride at Disney.
Christy and I watched you do
that from a safe distance.
Yeah.
We spent most of our time
trying to get an Instagramable photo.
You know how that is?
Did you get one?
Yes, you know what, she did gram one.
So, I think she got what she needed.
I always forget that that's
a thing that you can do.
I think it's just a sign of my age
that social media is still
just not a part of my DNA.
So I'm doing things--
Oh, I think you focused
on the right thing, man, that was good.
I know but, you mean,
this is what we do, man.
It's like if you're in a giant--
Oh, we're talking about it.
If you're in a giant swan,
you should get a picture of
yourself in a giant swan.
There's a freaking coffee shop out there.
I got a lavender.
You make it sound like it's
in the middle of the lake.
It's on the dock.
You have to walk through
a little coffee shop
that serves breakfast burritos
on the weekends, what?
Yeah, I love it.
I got a lavender latte and
I'm not ashamed of that.
I love when lavender is in things.
It's one of my favorite
flavors to be in things.
Something that seems like
it shouldn't be ingested.
Yeah, let's eat perfume.
That sounds like a good weekend.
This lavender latte made me so happy.
It's just almost as happy as
being in a swan on a lake.
Chasing swans, did you notice that?
You could chase other
swans with this giant swan.
Do you think that the little swans
believe that the giant swans are swans?
No.
You think they know they're inanimate?
You think they have a
concept of inanimatecy?
Is that a word?
I think they they're not of their kind.
I don't think they look at that thing
and register that it is trying
to impersonate them in any way.
Did you know that you did these swans,
on the weekends, you can go
out there until 10 o'clock
and you saw the light, the light.
Yeah, they got some LED--
The piping.
Piping on it.
Think about that.
You could go out there at night.
We could be like the
tourism board for Echo Park
if we don't watch out.
And then we paddled to the far end.
And by the way--
Oh, yeah, this is great.
The other the other boat was Jessie
and your sister-in-law, Teresa, and then--
My other niece.
Lily and then your older niece
who's closer in age to Lily.
Yeah.
Emery.
Mm-hmm.
Which they were hanging
out, it's really cool.
Christy had a good idea.
Very sweet.
Christy had a lot of good ideas,
we'll get to the second one.
And then she,
so we pedal all the way across.
We're like trying to keep
up with you and the kids,
which they got mad because
you wouldn't let them pedal.
No, no, no.
What's the story there?
No, no, no, no, no.
They kept switching off
so I would be on one side,
I was on the left side.
So, only two people can pedal at a time.
So I was like I'm gonna pedal
because I don't wanna be in the back
and have to deal with
two little kids up front
trying to direct where we're going.
It's hard to be funcle.
And so--
If you're not
in the driver seat.
I just let them rotate
in the other seat but then eventually,
they were mad, they wanted
me to be in the back
and they wanted to be driving
it and so, eventually,
I was gonna let them do that
but what's the first thing
that you noticed when you got out there?
It's really hard to paddle.
Yeah.
And you don't go anywhere.
I was like, "This is my
workout for the day."
Oh, man, I felt the burn.
Yeah, like really, I felt the burn
and then I felt the burn
when I went to the gym.
Whoo!
My trainer was like, "Okay,
we're gonna do squats,"
and I'm doing squats.
My back is back, man, and
now, I'm doing squats.
Oh, don't say it.
I mean we'll see how long it lasts.
Not a lot of weight though
but I was like, "Man!"
I was like having trouble, I was like,
"well, I did paddleboat this weekend."
Yeah, that's--
It's like I was the only person
to say that in the gym that morning.
I paddleboated too hard this weekend.
Well, you went
all the way to the--
Having trouble
with the squats.
Other side
and there's a group of people on the bank.
Yeah.
And you got there before we did
and you just sat in you're looking on
and then I pull up and it's a freaking--
Freestyle rap session, battle.
Rap battle.
It's a rap battle.
On the far end of Echo Park.
I love this town.
Like where can you go,
get a lavender latte,
get on a giant swan--
Swan.
And then paddle your way--
To a rap battle!
I mean--
Nowhere!
People always ask me
every time I go back
home to North Carolina.
They're like, "Do you like it out there?"
With so much skepticism
dripping in their voice.
We love it!
Hell yeah, I love it!
I love it!
Yeah.
And then, you know what?
You got the lavender latte, I
went out to use the bathroom
and there was a homeless man
with his ass in the sink.
Did you see that guy?
I love it here!
He was washing his ass?
That's a good enough place to start.
I didn't see that.
You didn't even tell me.
I didn't want you to go gawk at him.
I wanted the man to have his privacy.
The sun was setting, it was golden hour.
Man.
I mean for a man who takes a shower
and stares his neighbor's
down, I respected this guy.
Yeah, any choice.
I'm liking his dominance.
Yeah, and then your wife had a great idea.
We were trying to figure
out what we were gonna eat
and she said, "Well we can
go get some deep-dish pizza,"
and I was like--
Ding ding ding ding ding!
Say no more!
We were on the lake and then you started
pedaling for the shore before
she even told me where it was.
I haven't had deep-dish pizza in so long
and there's this place,
is that in Highland Park?
Where that place was?
It's Echo Park.
Masa?
Echo Park.
I don't know why it's called Masa.
That makes it sound like it might be
an Indian restaurant but it is,
it is straight up Chicago-style deep-dish,
takes an hour for them to bake a pie.
It's very reminiscent of
Lou Malnati's in Chicago
because we got the original, they call it,
which is sausage and mushroom
and it's got that corn bread crust stuff,
that's like the crispy
very cornmealy crust
and the sausage is a
giant piece of sausage
that's the same size as the pizza,
which I've only ever seen
that at Lou Malnati's
which I'm sure that's done
in other places but like,
we got pizza and Christy was like,
"You can only eat about
one piece of this stuff."
Oh, yeah, it's so huge.
So--
And when we finally got there
and I got to the crust of the first piece
and I'm like, I start to think, man,
it tastes so good, I want another piece
but I don't think I can
do it and I looked over
and you had, you were
at the crust as well.
And I thought for a second we
were on pace until you said--
That's my third piece.
This your third piece.
It's crazy.
You were going exceptionally slow though.
It's so dense.
It's so good, I had three
pieces and then I could--
You ate like the dense,
it's like eating a dense loaf of bread,
like eating the whole loaf.
Yeah, and then as I told
you then, I'll say again,
I could have had a fourth piece.
The only reason I didn't is
because y'all made me feel bad
about having three.
But to transition back,
these are the things that
friendships are made of.
Friendships are made of good times--
Rap battles, deep-dish pizza--
And bad times.
And LED light piping.
You can't really quantify a friendship
until you go through
some bad times together
and I even say plural.
It's basically going
through life together.
So as we go through these questions,
I think we'll get very specific
about some problems that pop up
and even how to maintain or
reconnect in a friendship,
things that we've been through.
We are no experts.
But we'll do our best.
But first, we wanna let
you know that mythical.com
continues to be the place to
go for all your mythical needs
and we've got this--
Let's call it the hub of happiness.
Yeah, we've got what we're
calling the Transcendental Tee.
We're just experimenting.
We're introducing new stuff
all the time over there.
Let me see the back of that one.
The back of it is a big
version of the front.
That is nice.
It says mythical in a lot of ways.
It's a little spooky.
It might be it might be
a kind of Illuminati.
Oh, I got to tell you, oh,
I gotta tell you, it's--
Did say Lou Malnati?
Speaking about Illuminati--
Deep-dish pizza.
I was literally at something recently
that I have to tell you
about and somebody brought up
on, ironically, Bohemian
Grove, Bohemian Grove.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
You gonna tell me about it?
I'm not gonna tell you about it now,
that's a secret, man, 'cause
I wanna get invited, man.
Oh.
You think you'll get invited?
I really hope so.
Go to mythical.com, the hub of happiness
because clothes make you happy.
Getting a new something
that you can wear--
That's the message here.
It's a little slice of happiness.
You wanna be happy, go
to the hub of happiness,
mythical.com.
And we're back on the
flip side of our ads.
You wanna get started with a question.
Do it.
This is from Caspooky which
is Casanora on Twitter,
she's changed her name to Caspooky.
It's a little dated after
Halloween, so that's why
she's changed it.
Yeah, well, she answered
this question before Halloween
so she was called Caspooky at the time.
"I have a friend that
chronically cancels last minute.
"We'll plan dinner or a hangout,
"I'll be halfway through cooking the meal
"or heading to her place when she texts me
"to say that she can't meet anymore
"less than one hour notice.
"She always seems so excited
up until she cancels!"
Sad emoji.
Yeah, this is extremely frustrating.
Christy had a friend who was like this.
A chronic canceller.
A chronic canceller back in the day
and so, I would hear about it.
She would complain to me
and I we wanted to make sure
that there wasn't some
unspoken thing going on.
It's like do you just feel
obligated to make plans
but you're not really
motivated to follow through
so you're looking for an excuse,
and the conclusion in
this particular example
was no, that wasn't the case.
There's some people who just,
they can't keep plans together.
But I would say it has to
be on the table to consider
is this an avoidance thing?
But let's assume it's not
because like she said,
she's very excited, always so
excited up until she cancels
and she's probably apologetic
or he's probably
apologetic or whatever, so.
It feels like it has
to be addressed, right?
So, I think honest communication
about the elephant in the room,
which is you're always canceling on me
needs to be specifically addressed
and I think that you could
no longer wonder is it about,
is this an avoidance thing?
Because you could just say, hey,
there seems to be a pattern
where we've got plans
and then you cancel
them at the last minute
and I just wanna know and I
want you to be honest with me,
is this something that's just related
to the way that you schedule your stuff
and it's just unfortunate circumstance
or is it that you just
don't wanna hang out?
Because I feel like I need
to know as your friend.
Yeah.
That's a tough, that's a
very tough thing to say
but I do feel like you gotta,
if you wanna actually make
progress in this area,
like you wanna pursue this friendship,
you got to take that head-on, right?
I think a through-line of everything
we're gonna talk about is gonna
be how key communication is.
I mean when you're left guessing,
you never know if you're right.
But I think that I'll
end up sharing a story
where I did choose to
communicate something
and it went sideways.
So, communication alone is not
the key, it has to be proper.
I think, and I don't know all the criteria
but I think if you try to have
as much humility as possible
so it's not a confrontation but,
like the way you said it, that
was like a humble approach.
It's like, hey, I just wanna
share how this makes me feel.
I actually don't know what to conclude,
I really would like to
hear from you about this
because be very careful
when jumping to conclusions
preemptively, especially
if it makes you upset,
aggressive, something like that.
And even me talking like
that, I started to get,
I start to wig out when it feels like
we're just giving advice.
It's like, I don't like
being those people.
So I like to share more
about just what we would do.
But I do think that in this instance,
you never know what the
other person is going through
or if they're just, they
may just be oblivious
to what they're doing and the
impact that it has on you.
Hey, I made dinner.
I mean we made plans.
I sacrifice doing other things
to make sure that we had this time
because that's what plans do.
Plans mean you're not planning
to do everything else.
And I would say that the
vast majority of the time,
assuming that what is going on
is this person is just
a little bit flighty,
you communicating that
this is a concern of yours
and pointing it out will,
I don't know, I'm not especially
schedule-oriented person
but I'm not very flighty either.
Like, if I say I'm gonna be somewhere,
I'm gonna be there but my assumption
is that people who are
kind of like scattered
is that all it takes,
what you're constantly doing
with somebody's got that personality
is you're kinda competing for
they're sort of unofficial
floating priorities.
Yeah.
And so, by simply expressing
concern about something,
you move yourself to the top of,
and so the next time you
say you've got plans,
they will be like, okay, I
know that I have a tendency
to kinda flake out so
I don't wanna do that
because Casanora said
that this was an issue
and so I'm going to honor that.
I think that's probably
what's gonna happen.
Now, if you can't make that,
if you can't communicate in that way,
if you're a person who just
avoids conflict at all costs,
then I think that you gotta make plan Bs.
I think you got to have a
back-up plan that you're okay,
you're not emotionally drained
by having to go to plan B.
So, you'll be like, all right,
I got plans with you-know-who
which means it might fall
through but if it doesn't happen,
I'm gonna eat a whole deep-dish pizza
and watch "Ghostbusters".
Okay, yeah.
You gotta have something
that you can look forward to
so that you don't get pissed at them.
Yeah.
But you can kinda reward yourself
and almost kind of hope they cancel.
Well, yeah, I definitely agree
that you got to find a way
to not harbor resentment
towards this person
because it's not gonna change overnight.
The type of person that does this
is gonna keep struggling with it
even if you having a great conversation.
It may take two or three times
but it's gonna happen again
so you have to find a way,
and maybe that's,
you invite them to things
where there's other people
so the plans aren't
contingent on that person
flaking or not flaking, you know?
Yeah, yeah, that's good.
So, it's like the thing can continue
and hey, you're invited if you wanna come
but I've changed the way
I invite you to things.
That's a good idea.
Yeah.
Let's move to another one.
I know that there was the one that,
it's like three different people.
Yeah, so, three different
people basically asked
a very similar question so I
will quickly read all these.
First ones from postcardhs.
"How do you reconnect with someone
"that you used to be best friends with?
"I had a best friend but ever ever since
"we went to different
schools, we stopped talking."
Second question from Cameron.
"If you haven't talked
to someone for a while
"and nothing really ended your friendship
"like a fight or moving away, et cetera,
"are you still friends with that person?
"Should you reach out
and have a conversation
"or should you just let it go?"
And lainey, "How do I
reconnect with a friend
"that I haven't hung out with regularly
"since elementary school.
"I have close neighborhood friends
"that stopped hanging out with me
"when our mutual friend died.
"Should I move on or try
to befriend them again?
"And if so, how?"
Hmm, it's interesting
because we've gone through life together
so we've always had each other
but we've also made really
good friends over the years
that I do,
I wonder if you would call it a pattern
of like losing connection, you know?
Everybody that we've connected with
and it's like we got the grade school
through high school friends,
had some tight friendships there,
then we had some really
tight college friends
and then we had, there's like
a few post-college people
and like I'm thinking of
specific people all along the way
that when we, especially
when we moved out here,
our friendship got more,
well, we made friends out here, you know?
But all those friends were
physically left behind but then,
I think it's a continuing pattern
of like not really
maintaining those friendships.
And we discussed on a previous podcast
about our issues with texting
and talking on the phone
and neither of us are
good at either of those
and we don't use texting
or talking on the phone
really as a way to connect with people.
It's usually a way to coordinate
some particular strategic action
and then you couple that with the fact
that everybody's busy, I understand
but our time is very much scheduled,
like we've got friends,
there's a lot of people
that we're friends with in Los Angeles
and you'll be on a text thread with them
and it'll be like 2:30 p.m. on a Wednesday
and all of a sudden, they
start texting each other
and they text each other
and they're like putting memes in there
and somebody's telling a story
and somebody's responding to it.
Right.
2:30 p.m. on a Wednesday,
95 times out of 100,
we're doing something that we just can't,
I can't just be like, I'm
gonna get out of this meeting
or this brainstorming
session or whatever it is
and enter into this text chat.
So, we don't--
For all intents and purposes,
before our working hours--
We're unavailable.
It's like we don't have
a phone for personal use.
And then when we get
home, it's like, okay,
I haven't seen my kids
and my wife all day,
I'm gonna spend some
quality time with them,
maybe I'll be able to stay up long enough
to watch a television show
with my wife if I can do it
but I'm gonna bed pretty
early so I can get up
and go to the gym.
It's like we don't leave a lot of space
for connecting with people
who are not close to us physically.
It's gotta be like okay, all right,
we're going out with this
couple on a double date
on Friday night or we're
having this event at my house.
Six weeks from now.
It's like a lot of it has to be booked
because then you got a couple
of nights on the weekend,
you got the stuff that
your kids have planned
that you got to attend and you got like,
okay, you got relatives coming
into town, like your nieces.
And so that weekend's off--
So, we have a difficult time
just keeping up with the
people in Los Angeles
and then you've got people who live
in different parts of Los Angeles
and if they're on the West side,
they might as well be in South Carolina.
And so then, everybody back
home in North Carolina,
people that you've been
friends with for a long time,
unless you're someone who can
text and talk on the phone
for extended period of time,
those friendships become,
like we've got a number of friendships
where I consider myself
very close to someone
that is in North Carolina and if we decide
to get together while
I'm in North Carolina
or they come out here,
we have a great time
and we pick up exactly where we left off
and I think we've all kind of accepted
this isn't the kind of friendship
that we're gonna be like
relying on each other
on a regular basis.
This is something we re-enter into.
Right, like two examples.
So Mike from from back in North Carolina,
work will bring him out here to California
and sometimes, it may not be too close
and maybe like Bakersfield
but then he'll make a point
and we're like with a
lot of advance notice
to like initiate with us and say,
"Hey, I'm coming into town,
can we get together one night?"
or "Let's go camping for a few nights."
We used to do that, like once a year,
we would go camping.
It was something that like,
he would always initiate it
because he was the one coming into town,
he would give his heads up and we would,
so we always make some time.
Lately, over the past couple years,
we haven't been able to make the time
for the camping like we used to do
but it's on his initiative.
Whenever I go back to North Carolina,
the time in is so limited,
I'm just prioritizing my family
and if I get to see one
friend when I'm there,
I'm very lucky 'cause it's
like the once a year trip.
And then you've got the other,
another example like
Eric who lives in Utah.
And so, when we go to,
he lives in Park City so
when we would go to Sundance,
well, I mean, if he found
out we were going there,
we didn't see him, that
would be an insult.
I mean, it's like, because,
I mean he's a high school friend,
he was in the Wax Paper Dogz with us.
We don't really communicate at all
except when we happen to see
him there or like when we went,
we went to something else.
Oh, when we had a show.
We introduced him to the
audience in Utah in Salt Lake.
Yeah, in Salt Lake City.
And so, but when we see
him or when we see Mike,
it's like the friendship picks
up right where it left off
and I think those are two
examples of like an understanding.
I think that in a lot of ways,
those individuals like Mike or Eric have,
I feel like they've kind of
adjusted to us in some way
but that's my assumption.
I know Mike, because I've
been friends with him
for a long time, is the kind of guy
who will get on the phone
and talk for a long time.
Like, his job requires him
to drive a lot of places
and he'll talk to people
on the phone and he can--
But he doesn't talk to you, right?
You don't talk to him on the phone.
No, very rarely.
It's like we'll text and
we'll get something set up
and then, of course, then we
have like long conversations,
the three of us once we're doing something
like camping together or whatever.
Right, and like we got the friend who,
he went back to Australia for like weeks.
Yeah.
And it's like, we're
really tight but it's,
like I find the conversations
that we have over text,
it's more like when you coming back.
Mm-hmm.
It's not like let's
continue our friendship
while you're gone because I'm just
so bad continuing a friendship over text.
So I find that it's like,
it's all just very practical.
And I think we've talked about that before
and like learning how
there is an opportunity
for text to be a legitimate way
to continue a friendship but
I have this sense of guilt and obligation
whenever like I fall out
of connection with somebody
and I think I just put that
on myself and over the years,
I feel like when the
two of us talk about it,
we've said things that
have made me feel better
that I don't know if
they're true or healthy
but we say things like
well, you know what?
I'm not good at text, I'm not
good at long-term friendships
but when I see him, it would be fine.
But like a great example is Greg.
We were super tight with Greg in college
and like he's working
up in Washington State
and doing his own thing
and like we saw him
we went on tour up
there, like they came in
but it's not like,
occasionally, he'll text me
and then we'll have an exchange that'll,
it'll fizzle out over
the course of 10 minutes.
And then in the past, there
would it be like let's have,
we would hop on the
phone a couple of times.
We'd have like an
hour-long catch-up session.
But like, I mean I love my mama
but I have a really hard
time calling her on the phone
and reconnecting.
But I have this sense of guilt
that's like I don't talk to
my mom enough or like I don't,
like, I wish that I had a
more of an active friendship
with Greg because he's so busy
with his work, much like us,
it's like he doesn't have the opportunity
to come down here and visit
and we don't have the opportunity
to go up there and visit
and so it's,
that's been difficult because I actually,
I've moved from feeling, I don't know,
I moved from feeling like
this is just the way it is.
I still love the guy
and I know he loves me
but the circumstances make it
whoa, our friendship can't be active
to feeling bad about it
and it kind of
back-and-forth, I don't know.
Yeah, I just,
I don't like, I don't want
to put that on myself.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I don't,
I know I can make all kinds of excuses
but I just don't want to,
I don't think it's
healthy for me personally
to sit around and feel guilty about it.
Yeah, yeah.
Now, it's one thing if the person
is going through something
specifically challenging
and they need me.
Yeah.
None of the people that I'm
thinking about right now
don't have some people in their lives
that can meet some of those needs.
I'm not enough I'm not
in a place to be like,
what can I do for you tangibly?
Mm-hmm.
And so, I have just kind
of become okay with.
The nature of these friendships
is that they pick up where
they left off when they do
and that's a great thing and
there's no hard feelings.
And I just feel like trying
to make anything more of it.
I don't know, I just feel
like I'm setting myself up
for disappointment,
both disappointment of myself
and them being disappointed in me
if I like start trying to
say hey, actually the dynamic
of this thing is gonna change,
like we're going to have this dynamic
long-distance friendship
via text or via phone call
every now and again.
I just know that it's not
gonna be a reliable thing
and I just don't wanna
begin it.
It's not realistic for you.
Yeah, I think it'll become more clear
that I do have some neurosis
associated with this
but I would like to believe,
to build on your point,
that if we heard that Greg
or someone in his family
was going through something,
that if we knew we could
be of help by being there,
that we would do everything we can
to drop what we're doing
to go up there, you know?
If there was something bad that happened,
if they were going through something.
But in the absence of that,
an occasional text, it's like,
hey, you crossed my mind, you know?
I still aspire to like, to
at least dabble in that.
Yeah.
And it's interesting because
we were closest with Greg
and then, in college,
and then Tim moved in
and then like Tim was
really close with Matt
and we got close to Matt
and then, you know, we got
a text from Matt yesterday
and all he was doing was asking
if we had listened to an album, you know?
Did you get that text because--
I did and I listened to the album
but you responded on the text thread
and then I never got around
to responding on the text thread,
which is an interesting
thing that happens sometimes
where if somebody is sending
something to the both of us,
whether it's an email or a text,
I've got this thing in my mind
that if one of us responds,
the other one isn't obligated to
and I know that that's not what this was,
this wasn't a business thing.
This was like hey have you
listened to this album?
Yeah.
And so I was actually thinking
about that a second ago.
I was like, yeah, I haven't
gotten back on that text thread
to be like, I also don't like the album
that you recommended.
But I only listened to it one time.
And so then he was like,
"Oh, you gotta listen to
it two or three times."
So then I was like, okay, I'm gonna listen
to this album again and
then I'm gonna get in
on the text thread
but I could also just say
that on the text thread.
But I think it was cool that,
and he, like, either every single time
or the vast majority of time,
he initiates the
conversation because we just,
like I don't know if we've ever
initiated a text with Matt.
But like every month or so,
there's like a little exchange
and it's actually valuable
for me to like, for what it is
and for me not to attach
some sort of guilt
that I'm not doing more.
It's also also valuable
because he's introduced us,
Matt is the one who
introduced us to Sturgill
and then Jason Isbell.
I don't think Sturgill
'cause I think we went
in Amoeba Records and I
literally saw the record
and I was like who is this?
Okay, well, I know for a fact
he introduced me to Jason Isbell.
And I am as thankful for that
as any music recommendation
that I've ever gotten.
Oh, wow, and then you've got Tim,
who I think because of
result of some of the stories
we told on this podcast
that he started to reach out
to discuss those with us and--
Correct our errors.
Correct our errors but it led to like--
Fact check.
Us having more of a
conversation and connecting more
and I really enjoyed that.
It was like, it was a
little odd that's like,
okay, he's listening to "Ear
Biscuits" and then he's,
and I'll tell you why it was odd.
I'll try to articulate that,
and then because he's probably listening.
But it felt odd to me
'cause it was just like,
okay, he's sitting on a
conversation we're having
but we're not having it
with him, so it's like,
I don't know, I have all this
guilt associated with friends
because I'm like, I feel bad
you're listening to our podcast
but you can't be here at the table
to be a part of the conversation.
Like if we were,
if we had an active friendship
like we used to have,
like, you'd have a seat at the table.
And I know that's not
healthy and I don't know,
he's not thinking that
but I start to think like,
if Greg or Tim or Matt
listen to our podcast,
did they start to feel like
we're not good friends
or something to them
because we never initiate
conversations with them.
I don't know why I attach so much
guilt to these things but I do.
Actually, I guess I'll share this story
where it really came to a head.
A friend out here in LA,
and I'm gonna try to be very
careful when telling this story
because this story's about me.
It's not about him at all.
But it's about a text exchange that I had
because I was,
he's a friend that, like, we
were close a couple years ago
like right when we move to LA but then,
it was like, because purely,
because of circumstantial reasons,
we fell out of being in contact.
Like it went from seeing
each other every week
or every few weeks.
Even if you didn't plan
it, we would see each other
and having little conversations
then kind of trickles
into, hey, let's make plans
or we're going here for
lunch, you wanna come
type of thing too like none of that.
We're just in different circles.
Kind of like what some people
ask, how do you reconnect?
And so then, it would be like
once, maybe twice a year,
we'd see each other or he would come over
and we would have this
reconnection session
that would be like an
hour or maybe two hours.
And it would be great to reconnect
but then it would it would
be like radio silence
from both parties for a long time.
And I guess one day,
it caught me at a bad time
that he decided to text me out of the blue
and it was just a friendly text.
It was something like, miss
you, man or thinking about you.
And
I've been struggling with, in general,
and you know where the story's going
but I was struggling
with if I feel something
or if I think something, I should say it.
So, just in general, like
I'm trying to become a person
who's more honest about what I'm thinking
or feeling or going through
or how I feel like I
should respond to somebody
and I thought it would
be a healthy practice
for me to respond to his texts
with exactly what I thought,
what I thought in the moment.
And but what I was thinking was,
well, you know what?
I'll read what I wrote back.
Okay, I remember this.
He's like, "Dude, I miss you."
That was his text.
Again, this is about me, not him.
That was all his text said.
And I was like, I'm just gonna,
I got a lot of feelings are
coming up in me and I just,
and this is what I wrote.
"Hey, man, thanks for the message.
"Honestly, it's very tough
for me to know how to respond
"so I'll just be real about it.
"I care about you but I just
don't have time in my life
"where I'm at right now
with family and work
"to devote enough time to take
the friendship we had before
"and make it work now.
"There are a few friends in my life now
"that I'm actively trying to maintain
"a quality friendship with
"and it is proving to be very difficult
"purely from a practical standpoint.
"I wish it weren't the
case but I respect you
"and wanted to be honest
about it so I'm writing this
"from a place of love.
"Thanks for hearing me out, man."
And you're laughing because
why on earth would anybody
who has an ounce of
kindness in their heart
write this in response to a friend
who simply wrote "Dude, I miss you."
Right, is that what you're laughing at?
Well, no, I'm laughing
because it's just such a Link thing.
It's just, it's comical to me.
It was an experiment in honesty
because well I feel guilty about,
everything that I felt is true.
As your best friend, I
wanna comment on that
because I find that very
interesting that that,
first of all, I think your
instincts are great, right?
I think that the guilt that
you feel about friendships
and your sense of obligation
and your obligation to
be honest with people
and these are all really good things.
This shows that you're
a person of character.
I think that it's interesting
that you made a conscious
decision to be like,
I feel like I need to
say what I think more
because on the spectrum of
people who say what they think,
you're pretty high on the spectrum
of the frequency with which
you say what you think--
Candor.
Is pretty high, potentially
the highest of anyone
that I know personally.
Okay, okay.
If you can name a person
who says what they think about
things more often than you
that we know collectively,
I would be interested to
know who that person is.
I can think of one person that we knew
and I didn't much like this
person for that reason.
So.
That person would always say
exactly what they thought.
And so, and of course--
With no concern for how
it would be received.
And so, yeah, and my tendency,
not that I don't talk a lot,
not that I don't have a lot of opinions
but in certain situations like this,
it's just like I'm always gonna be on team
just say something to be nice
to just keep things where they're at.
Don't push away and don't pull that,
like my tendencies to say something
that just kind of keeps
things at a stasis.
That's just my instinct, I'm
not saying it's good or bad
but in every type of interaction,
I don't wanna move things
further in either direction
and that's just my sort
of knee-jerk response
to any kind of interaction like that.
Well, it just drove me crazy to feel like
I respected this person,
this friend of mine
that I couldn't give them what I felt like
a true friend would give and so just,
I felt like I needed
to define the relationship, so to speak.
Well, and I--
Out of respect.
But I will say in addition to this,
to add more color to this situation
without getting into specifics,
that this person was going
through something difficult
and had reached out to both of us
and spent some time kind of catching us up
on what they were going through
and it was obvious,
it was obvious that they wanted
and needed friends to kinda
help them get through this situation.
And so there was a,
we had similar interactions.
You with him and then
me with him separately.
I don't think we got
together the three of us.
No.
And I felt like, it was weird for me
because I was like, I don't
think I can give this person
what they need right now for a number
of really complex reasons but I just,
and so and maybe, you communicate,
he didn't sent me a text
that said, "I miss you,"
because I assume that
when you're interacting,
you felt more of an obligation to be like,
okay, I can see what this guy needs
and I'm going to try to give it to him,
which that's not good on
me, that's good on you.
I mean I'm probably giving out the vibe
that's just like, okay
I can see that Rhett
is not available to me in this way.
And so, but he may have thought
that you were available to him in that way
so you probably sensed
a little bit of pressure
when he sends that text.
It's like hey, I still need
you to help me through this.
And his response was
very gracious, very kind
but it was also clarifying that,
I mean he was basically saying
I was just being friendly,
this wasn't coming from a place of me
needing something from you.
I just wanted,
it was more of just like
a friendly, we're friends.
Just checking in.
Yeah, it was just like,
and it wasn't anything more than that.
And there was a little
bit of an exchange there
where we clarified what each other meant
and then a day later, I
wrote back one last thing
and I said, "I read back through my text
"and just wanted to apologize
"for giving what must have
felt like a cold-hearted
"out of the blue response
to a friendly kind text.
"I was trying to respect
you by being honest
"about what I was able to give
"even though you were
not asking for anything
"and I'm sorry if it insulted
or otherwise hurt you.
"you deserve better and I think
"that's what I was
actually trying to say."
And he responded, "I appreciate that."
And that, I mean, because
of my experiment in honesty,
I'll call it, air quotes,
that was apparently the
end of our friendship.
It was definitely the
end of that exchange.
I mean I guess that was my message.
It was like I love you and respect you
but I don't have time to
invest in a friendship
in the way that I think you deserve,
therefore, I just needed
to get this off my chest
and break up with you?
Like, I regret it.
I think about when am I gonna
cross paths with this guy
in a Ralphs grocery store,
on the street or something
and like I often think
about what I'm going to say.
And now, I'm tortured by
that, you know, it's like--
Well, so let's get back to
her question though, right?
Yeah.
Because I think maybe we have
different perspectives
on this and that's fine.
And I'm not just saying this is my advice
because this is what I do because I don't,
it isn't that I don't feel
guilty about it at all
like, when we talk about it in this way
but I think I've made a decision
and maybe this is a decision
out of self-preservation
but I mean one of the
things that I have learned
in therapy is that
it's okay to make decisions
that have your own health,
your own mental well-being in mind,
and I think that, you know,
we come from a place
where I think that there is
a sense that
self-sacrifice is super important
and kinda always putting
other people's needs
before yours is super important
and I, in principle,
agree with those things,
in principle, right?
But there's sometimes, just because,
like sometimes, your needs are actually,
you got to think about what your needs are
and you have to think about
the reality of a situation.
And so I think the way that I interact
with these long-term
friendships is this like,
okay, when I have the opportunity,
like a real opportunity
whether that's a text exchange,
even if it's just initiated
by the other person
or it's seeing them in person,
I wanna be present and
I wanna be available
and I want to be invested in
the friendship for that time
but then, when we're
not physically together
and that we kinda go back to our own lives
because we're not in a situation
that we're gonna be brought
into each other's presence
on a regular basis,
I'm going to be okay with the fact
that there's not much of
a friendship in the gaps.
And I'm gonna be okay with that
because I feel like
trying to make anything
beyond that happen,
it's gonna be something
that I'm not going to be good at it
and it's not gonna be a regular thing
and it's only going to
lead to disappointment.
If we can have an understanding
that there's not gonna be much here
until we see each other again,
and hey, let's be open to that.
Let's try to make that happen,
if we're gonna be in the
area, I'm gonna let you know
so we can get together.
Like, let's be proactive about planning.
Hey, let's go to see a game
back in Raleigh together
or something like that or hey,
we're coming to your town,
come out to our show and let's hang out.
My advice to these three people
who are asking about different
situations, it's like,
and I don't know if,
some of these situations may
not be like a long distance,
it may just be like I was
friends with this person
and now, I'm not.
My tendency is just to be like
friendships are very difficult
but I don't, I don't know if,
it depends on the
situation but I don't know
if it's worth it to be like,
all right, I'm going to
place the burden on myself
that if I don't, if this
friendship is not rekindled,
there's something wrong with me.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I don't think, I don't
think you have to force it.
Yeah, I do think,
I appreciate what you're
saying, it's helpful
because I think friendships are,
it's a reciprocating
cyclical process, you know?
It's a relationship and
there's give and there's take
and take and give.
And it takes both parties being
on enough of the same page
to continue to move a friendship forward.
So if you're wanting to,
if you're the one wanting
to rekindle the friendship,
you got to respect the fact
that that person on the other end of that
might not be in a position
to make that happen
or exactly the way that
you would want it to
or envision it coming together, if at all.
In the clarifying exchange
that I have with with my friend
and I do still call him a friend,
he clarified that he knew
but based on the fact
that he like, whenever
conversation happen,
it would be on his initiative.
So he said, "I actually understand that.
"So me reaching out was just a kindness."
There were no strings attached.
I think that's why I feel bad
is that like I made
assumptions where there,
I made wrong assumptions
about why he was saying
and that like there were strings attached
that they weren't which
then it was presumptuous
where he was just being nice, you know?
Yeah.
But I think,
I mean relationships are dicey
and so you've got to be,
and you can't, like you
said, you can't force,
you can't force something to
work if it's not gonna work
and that doesn't mean you
shouldn't try but you should,
I think your advice is
initiate lightly and just
see what comes of it.
I mean it's just like in
a romantic relationship
if you're really into somebody,
you can't lead a horse
to water, so to speak.
You can't make somebody
fall in love with you.
But don't date a horse.
Especially if they're a horse.
Don't date a horse.
I mean it's much more,
we don't, I think we fall back on thinking
of friendships as being this thing
that's like, oh, it's so
easy and it just happens
and it's like, aren't I likable?
Aren't you likable?
Well, then, can't we be friends?
It's like, there's a
lot of freaking factors.
It's very, I mean in many
ways, it's just as challenging
as a romantic relationship.
I think that we may be thinking about this
in a very narrow way because of our age.
Mm-hmm.
Because we just assumed,
again, we've already established
that we're not great at
connecting with people digitally.
Mm-hmm, yeah.
Via phone or text or heck,
I've got a VR headset now.
I could sit down in a room
with someone who's got one.
And maybe physical proximity
will continue to become
less and less a factor
in maintaining a friendship
and maybe that has already happened
and because I think what
I just said a second ago
is that hey, listen, if
we're together physically,
I wanna make an effort to be there for you
and to be a listening ear and
to catch up and to be present
but if we're not physically
present together,
the best I'm going to do is just try
to be proactive about opportunities for us
to be physically present
together that are practical.
And maybe that's a really
narrow way to look at it.
I understand that about myself
and you might be like hey, guys, listen,
my best friends are people
that are in different countries
that I connect with
that I video chat with.
what is this?
Right.
Most of the people that
we're talking about
are kinda like us, of our generation
and we're not video chatting
with a lot of people
in the way that like our kids will just,
you were talking about Lincoln
just being on like a constant video chat
with a group of friends.
Yeah.
On that like Houseparty
app or whatever it was.
Yeah.
And I understand, okay, this generation,
this next generation is different
so maybe our advice is not
very applicable to them.
So I don't know where you're
at with these situations.
I would just say that if you
feel like you need that person,
like you need that friendship
or they might need that friendship,
then I think, like you said,
sort of initiating but not
initiating where, don't,
I just, the idea of putting
a burden on yourself
and feeling this,
all of a sudden there's a
negative obligation or guilt
that's associated with your
interaction with that person,
to me, I just don't like that negativity.
When I think about somebody
we went to college with,
I've got good memories and
I think about the next time
we're hanging out, we're
gonna have a good time
but I don't wanna think about
and then every other
time I think about them,
all I do is just associate guilt
with the fact that I
don't talk to them enough.
Yeah, it's not--
It doesn't seem healthy.
It's not.
So how can I focus on
what the positive is?
But like you said, if they're
going through something,
they need somebody to talk to,
they need somebody to show up for them
whether that's physically or digitally,
then I hope that I can do that,
and I feel an obligation to do that.
But that doesn't mean, in every sense,
it's appropriate or the
right choice for you
to even do that.
Right.
I think we do need to say that.
It's like just because
somebody needs a friend,
there has to be scenarios
where that doesn't automatically mean
you have to be that friend.
Right.
So, I'm just trying to tip the scales
and I'm saying that more for myself.
And again, that wasn't actually the case.
I think I might have brought
some of that assumption
but that wasn't the case with
this scenario that I explored.
But I actually don't
know where you, is it?
Where do you come down
on this text exchange?
That, I mean if you're saying
you would have just been nice
and like you would have
continued the niceties
and then I mean, and then the opposite,
that's one extreme, right?
Is it not?
And the other extreme
is clearly what I did,
which is basically
break off the friendship
because I couldn't be
everything I thought I had to
be which wasn't even the case.
I don't know.
I mean, I definitely am, like I said,
my tendency is to maintain
the status quo and I don't,
I really don't like
uncomfortable situations.
I don't like awkwardness,
I don't like conflict
and so it's really difficult for me
when I'm not like, okay,
I need to be honest with this person
so that we can clarify where we're at
so we can actually reach
some sort of conclusion.
Like I'm much more likely to be like,
okay, this is going to
be this sort of thing
that just indefinitely continues
and isn't really that
big of an inconvenience.
It's easy to just send back a text
that says, miss you too, man.
But when it's like, hey,
let's get together and do this
and it's like, I've got these people
that I feel like I need to prioritize
because they're like
more in my inner circle
and I can't say yes to them right now
and give them what I want to give them.
Forget what they need, what I
wanna give them as a friend,
then at that point, you got to,
you're just lying and saying,
actually I can't get
together, I have plans.
It's like you're just letting
people read between the lines.
It's like okay, you can
see that you're initiating.
I'm not a bad person for just,
I think most people can get the message.
It's like hey, it's not
that I don't like you,
it's just that I don't have capacity.
Yeah, I think my theory
is that you arrive at the same result
with a little less awkwardness.
And it might take a little
bit longer to get there
for somebody to get the message.
Like, oh, he's not really available.
I don't necessarily think
that one is better or worse.
You were ripping the Band-Aid off,
I'm letting the Band-Aid
fall off in the shower.
You know what I'm saying?
And maybe it should
have come out a little--
I wouldn't shower with someone
who's not that close of
a friend but go ahead.
Maybe the Band-Aid should have come off
a little bit earlier
but I tend to,
it really takes a lot for me
to have an uncomfortable
conversation with somebody, so--
Well, I--
I tend to--
I need to take this to therapy, clearly.
Yes, you do.
I mean I think there's
probably some deep-rooted
fear of abandonment thing
that then I don't wanna
put on other people
even when they're not even expecting
or fearing that themselves.
I would say that that would
be something to look for.
I think it's probably
something in that arena.
So, I mean we can leave it at that.
Okay.
It seems I'm pressing
you to solve my problem.
I don't have a solution.
I'm just telling you the
way that I would do it
and it tends to be okay.
Yeah.
I've definitely slowed my role
on saying what I'm thinking,
which brings it back to this still
may be obnoxious at times
level that you're used to.
I don't know how much help we've been.
We didn't answer a lot of questions.
We did answer three questions at once.
You know what?
It was--
And we took a lot,
I mean it was more--
Hey, it was helpful for me, thank you.
We did what we often do which
is we take your questions
and then we make it--
So what?
So you're now, you're
apologizing for that?
An internal exploration of
our own lives but hopefully,
we're all learning together
as a large community
and hopefully, we're getting
better at doing things,
friendships, as we go.
I quite enjoyed the conversation
and I'm kind of nervous about
it going out there but--
Why?
Whatever.
You got nothing to apologize about
and if you do, you will.
I do have a Rec in Effect and--
Okay.
Mine is a book that I am listening to
that everybody's talking about this book.
Oh, you gotta read it or listen to it.
I'm half way through it, it's
captivating us enthralling.
It's "Catch and Kill" by Ronan Farrow.
So, of course, Ronan
Farrow, he is most known
as being Woody Allen and Mia Farrow's son
even though he, for
understandable reasons,
likes to distance himself
from his famous parents
and he has a career of
his own as a journalist
and he was the--
Lot of help you just gave him.
He was the one who was very instrumental
in sort of breaking the
Harvey Weinstein's story.
Ah.
And it's just this incredibly
engrossing tale of him
trying to get to the bottom of the story
and just be able to report it
and all the crazy stuff
that he encountered
in the process of going after someone
as big and as powerful and
as with as many connections
as Harvey Weinstein.
Just fascinating story.
So it's a docu-novel.
Yeah, and his, the audiobook,
which he was actually,
some people made fun of him for this
but I thought it was great.
Oh, okay.
He does all the voices for his audiobook
and he like does like
impersonations of the people
that he spoke with whether
they be Australian,
British or a woman with a sultry voice
and he basically just does all the accents
an he does a really
good job at it, I think.
But it's nonfiction.
It's not a fiction.
This is all any place,
like there's a recording,
there's the famous recording
of Harvey Weinstein
that one of the actresses
that he was harassing took.
Wow.
And it's in there.
Anyway, fascinating story if
you're into that kind of thing.
"Catch and Kill".
I'm recommending the audiobook
because that's what I've listened to
but I'm sure it's a great
book to read as well.
Okay, thanks for hanging
out with us, hashtag.
Oh, every time I say hashtag now,
I wanna say #BLEAKCREAK
because we've been--
Well, you know what?
Promoting the novel so much.
Keep talking about
"Bleak Creak".
#EarBiscuits.
You can use both of them.
If you wanna talk about
#BLEAKCREEK on #EarBiscuits,
we don't care how many #hashtags you use.
But you know what?
You can hashtag count on
us hashtag being back again
next week just like we
are most every week.
And you know what?
Being your friend.
Yeah.
You know what?
We'll be your friend, #FRIENDS.
We're your friends.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.